[Musik]
wie soll man das unsagbare aussprechen
den eigenen vater verraten den eigenen
onkel
kinder die opfer von sexuellem
missbrauch geworden sind reden selten
darüber weil ihnen nicht bewusst ist
dass ihnen falsches widerfahren ist weil
sie sich schuldig fühlen oder ganz
einfach aus axt
fünf frauen treten aus dem schatten sie
sind zwischen 16 und 72 jahre alt einige
hatten glück und es gab jemanden der
ihnen in der kindheit zuhörte
andere mussten jahrelang schweigen
es sind unterschiedliche geschichten von
kleinen mädchen die aber alle ähnliches
erzähle wie schwierig es war das
schweigen zu brechen von der ablehnung
durch die familie der belastung bei
einem gerichtsverfahren
heute sind sie froh dass sie es
geschafft haben zu reden und sie hoffen
dass man ihnen nun endlich zuhört
[Musik]
langsam wurde es nacht ich schaute neben
ihm fern
ein sofa stand hier und ein anderes tag
lang gehe ich schau dir also fern
mein blick war auf den bildschirm
gerichtet aber ich sah meinen vater aus
dem augenwinkel und
ich saß da und bekam mit meinem rechten
auge mit wie mein vater plötzlich begann
seine hose herunterzuziehen
[Musik]
ich fühlte mich unwohl er berührte sich
und schaute mich an
ich war wie versteinert und wagt er
nicht richtig hinzuschauen
ich erinnere mich daran keinen speichel
mehr im mund zu haben ich wusste dass
das nicht normal ist
mein herz hat sich zusammen gezogen aber
ich habe weiterhin versucht auf den
fernseher zuschauen
ich hatte angst er
hat weitergemacht und dann ist er zu mir
gekommen
er ist näher zu mir hin gekommen
er sagte also er nahm meine hand und
legte sie auf sein geschlecht
er begann damit bewegungen zu machen hin
und zurück als kleines kind wusste ich
nicht was das bedeutet ich hatte in
meinem leben noch nie ein männliches
geschlechtsteil gesehen ich wusste nicht
einmal wie das aussah
für mich hat es eine ewigkeit gedauert
das ging so weiter und dann hat er
meinen kopf genommen und gesagt lutscher
da habe ich nein gesagt nein ich will
nicht
ich begann zu weinen er fragte warum
willst du nicht lucio lucio
er hat meinen kopf nach unten und ganz
nah an sein geschlechtsteil gedrückt
und dann in diesem moment wurde ich
gerettet weil mein kopf war ja ganz nah
dran
und dann hat er das auto meiner mutter
gehört
da hat er mich gelassen er hat meine
beiden hände so gepackt und gesagt du
sagst nicht sonst bring ich dich um
chloe ist sieben jahre alt als der
missbrauch stattfindet
der vater wurde inzwischen verurteilt
aber damals glaubt das kleine mädchen
den drohungen des vaters leidet unter
alpträumen
erst als ihre eltern sich scheiden
lassen kann sie das schweigen brechen
eines tages vielleicht elf monate danach
ich erinnere mich nicht mehr genau
da sagt meine mutter meinem vater er
solle gehen
er verlässt das haus definitiv und da
fühle ich mich sicher genug es zu
erzählen
da habe ich es meiner mutter erzählt
ich bin märkte die tränen in ihren augen
und fragte sie was ist denn los ich
wusste nicht was los war dachte es würde
ihr etwas weh tun sie sagt nein mama
wenn ich dir das erzähle sagst du papa
nichts was ist denn passiert wenn du ihm
davon erzählt wird er mich töten
das hat mich beunruhigt und ich wollte
wissen was geschehen war da hatten wir
alles im detail erzählt
es gibt keine worte um auszusprechen was
eine mutter in einem solchen moment
fühlt
das erzählen ist schwierig denn ich weiß
dass meine mutter meinem vater vertraut
hat ich weiß aber auch dass ich es sagen
muss zu keinem augenblick hat sie meine
worte in frage gestellt hätte sie mir
nicht geglaubt dann hätte ich niemals
mehr davon erzählen können und mein
leben lang darüber geschwiegen
wie die meisten gewaltdelikte innerhalb
der familie ist die schlimmste tag weil
sie durch primären bezugspersonen
begangen wird durch personen die die
sicherheit des kindes gewährleisten
sollten so gibt es nicht nur eine
psychische schädigung durch den
sexuellen missbrauch sondern auch eine
sehr tief liegende schädigung des kindes
in bezug auf bindungen
so gesehen ist es das schlimmste delikt
chloe wurde nur einmal opfer eines
inzest verbrechen
claire musste unsittliche berührungen
schon als kleinkind erfahren doch erst
in der pubertät konnte sie die wahrheit
aussprechen
ein langer schmerzhafter prozess
es ist der vater man kann sich nicht
vorstellen dass er böses tun könnte
in meinem fall war es etwas so
alltägliches von klein auf es war wie
ein teil meiner erziehung
es war also sehr kompliziert für mich zu
verstehen dass diese sache diese
handlungen die seit immer existierten
und die mir auf den ersten blick normal
vorkamen
eben nicht normal waren
klar ist 16 jahre alt ihre aussage wird
anonymisiert weil sie sich derzeit in
einem laufenden rechtlichen verfahren
gegen ihren vater befindet
ich stand meinem vater sehr nahe sehr
sogar er nannte mich seine prinzessin er
stellte mich allen als seinen schatz als
seinen stolz vor ich war im grunde
genommen sein glück
hast du deinen vater zu diesem zeitpunkt
geliebt ja ja ich stand meinem vater
sehr nahe ich denke dass es noch mal für
kinder ist die die liebe ihrer eltern
erfahren glücklich zu sein als kind will
man nichts anderes als die liebe die
aufmerksamkeit der eltern die
anerkennung lang mein vater gab mir
alles von der
[Musik]
als ich klein war während der ganzen
zeit in der ich mit meinem vater
zusammen lebte kam er in mein zimmer
manchmal verbrachte er dort sogar die
nacht er schlief bei mir und berührte
mich so als wäre nichts dabei so als
wäre es normal er nannte dies gute nacht
umarmungen es war normal
es waren keine umarmungen kein vater der
abend seiner tochter gute nacht sagt das
weiß nicht es waren unsittliche
berührungen
[Musik]
als sie älter wird lässt claire immer
weniger gute nacht umarmungen zu
als sich ihre eltern trennen will sie
nicht bei ihrem vater übernachten sie
schreibt ihm einen brief
[Musik]
weshalb ich wütend bin ich möchte wie
eine reife 13-jährige behandelt werden
keine lächerlichen spitznamen mehr
kleines köfferchen kleines kätzchen
keine küsse mehr auf den mund ich will
nicht mehr dass du bei mir schläfst kein
streicheln mehr keine nächtlichen
besucher mehr nicht dass du dich nackt
auf mein bett wirfst mitten in der nacht
es steht alles in diesem brief alles als
ich ihn los lass ich ihn als brief eines
kleinen mädchens das über dinge sprach
diaz störten
ich habe die worte nicht wirklich ernst
genommen nein ich habe nichts bemerkt
alles ist drin und ich habe es nicht
kapiert
claire bleibt dabei sie weigert sich
beim vater zu übernachten da schreitet
die kinder und erwachsenenschutz behörde
caspar ein und das mädchen beginnt zu
reden
[Musik]
es gab da eine stimme in mir die
herausschreien wollte er hat mich da
berührt rede
und ich habe geredet und ich hatte glück
diese stimme zu hören den mut zu haben
zu reden
die gutachterin schaut mich an und sagt
das nennt man unsittliche berührungen
und dass ich ihn verklagen solle denn
dies sei nicht normal
danach habe ich es meine mutter erzählen
müssen das war sehr aufwühlend für mich
ich glaube es war das schwierigste
überhaupt
meiner mutter das gefühl zu geben dass
sie mich nicht beschützt hat
man ist fassungslos im wahrsten sinne
des wortes
weil
ich erinnere mich dass ich eine
geschichte zuhörte als würde mich diese
nichts angehen
[Musik]
und dann treffen einen die einzelheiten
wie schläge und man weint man weint und
dann folgt die zeit der schuldgefühle
man sagt sich wie konnte ich das alles
nur übersehen
es gab da schon dinge die mich stört
[Musik]
dass er immer an jack liebte das aber
ihr übernachtete
ich habe den unterschied nicht gesehen
zwischen einem liebevollen vater der
einen zärtlichen umgang mit seiner
tochter pflegt und jemandem der sich so
verhält
da kommen große schuldgefühle hoch die
ich immer noch haben
[Musik]
schnell muss der missbrauch ist etwas um
vertretbares wenn man in einer gesunden
familie aufwächst innerhalb gesunde
beziehungen dann gibt es dinge die man
sich einfach nicht vorstellen kann
deshalb kommt es vor dass eltern mütter
gewisse dinge zwar warnen sich aber
einfach nicht vorstellen können dass
diese dinge so weit gehen wie inter
solange die kinder keine notsignale
geben solange nicht eindeutig
gravierendes signalisiert wird können
sie es sich nicht vorstellen
[Musik]
sobald das schweigen innerhalb der
familie gebrochen wird stellt sich für
die opfer die frage ob sie die aussagen
auch nach außen tragen wollen
das würde bedeuten die taten der polizei
zu melden und ein langes juristisches
verfahren in kauf zu nehmen denn alle
klagen im zusammenhang mit sexuellen
handlungen an kindern werden von amtes
wegen verfolgt
[Musik]
in folge sobald man redet die wahrheit
erzählt das war für mich wie eine
einstürzende sandburg
man muss zur polizei das war für mich
grauenvoll
anfangs war ich nicht fähig mit einem
mann zu sprechen es musste bei der
polizei eine frau sein am anfang weiß
minderjährige opfer von sexuellen
übergriffen werden von der sittenpolizei
angehört
seit 2010 arbeiten die speziell dafür
ausgebildeten beamten und beamtinnen mit
einem neutralen fragenkatalog der keine
beeinflussung der minderjährigen zulässt
das wort eines kindes steht im zentrum
der ermittlungen es wird im verfahren
verwendet und ist ein beweismittel
deshalb wird die anhörung gefilmt und
dem kind wird erklärt dass es seine
aussagen nicht wiederholen muss
das protokoll erlaubt uns den dingen auf
den grund zu gehen ohne jemals fragen zu
stellen die das kind zu einer antwort
verleiten könnten
dem kind werden keine fragen gestellt
wie war es dein papa der dies getan hat
oder der großvater der onkel oder der
großvater oder tatsächlich werden nie
direkte fragen gestellt wir wollen dass
die worte vom kind gesprochen werden
dass es die eigenen worte sind sobald es
einen begriff verwendet kann dieser
begriffen und aufgenommen werden und
dann werden wir das kind auffordern
weiter zu sprechen
ja und dann erzählen mir mehr und dann
erzähle mir von dir zu diesem zeitpunkt
wenn das kind diese dinge nicht erlebt
hat wird es nicht in der lage sein sie
zu erfinden weil wir es ihm nicht
eingeredet haben was jungs ihr edel-fan
wie ist das wenn man als 14 jährige
seinen eigenen vater anzeigt
das macht angst ich musste reden und das
war schwer zu ertragen mann entblößt
sich man fühlt sich wirklich dreckig ich
würde es kein zweites mal tun
es gibt anhörungen in denen nichts an
die oberfläche kommt das kommt sogar
häufig vor es ist sehr schwer
herzukommen und auszusagen wir betonen
auf das wir polizistinnen sind und
spezialisiert aber vor unbekannten über
sex zu sprechen das ist sehr schwer
[Musik]
würdest du dich damals schuldig seinen
vater anzuzeigen
ich war dermaßen wütend ich hatte eine
riesige wut in mir und
da mein vater bild zerstört war hatte
ich auch kein mitgefühl mir
hat das du angst hast dein vater wegen
seiner anklage ins gefängnis muss nein
ich hatte keine angst ich sagte mir dass
es so sein soll
als ich verstanden hatte dass es nicht
normal ist ab diesem moment war die
liebe für ihn weg ich will dass er ins
gefängnis muss
und hier steht das haus
sind sie dort aufgewachsen dort bin ich
aufgewachsen
ein haus voller erinnerungen ja
das haus meiner albträume
ist das haus der schreie das haus der
gewalt des missbrauchs der manipulation
der verletzenden worte
und der eltern
[Musik]
der eigentlich kranken eltern die bei
home alleine rum fat
marie sprunger ist hier aufgewachsen in
einem kleinen dorf im berner jura
im ländlichen stark religiös geprägten
umfeld ist es vor 40 jahren ein tabu
über inzest zu sprechen das kleine
mädchen muss den missbrauch im stillen
erdulden
in meinen erinnerungen tut mein vater
was er getan hat in dem moment als er
mich schlägt
wenn er mich schlägt zieht er mir die
kleider aus und fasst mich dort an wo er
nicht sollte
es passiert während eines gewaltaktes
das passiert nicht
also mein vater kommt nicht nach zehn
mann bett es fand vor allem dann statt
wenn ich geschlagen wurde ist er
manchmal weitergegangen
schwer für mich es auszusprechen
mein vater haben mich nicht mit seinem
geschlechtsteil penetriert aber er ist
mit seinen fingern in mich eingedrungen
und das hat die gleiche psychologische
wirkung backt
ecologic und mailing wo befindet sich
ihrer mutter zum zeitpunkt der schläge
und des missbrauchs
manchmal ist sie anwesend manchmal nicht
manchmal steht sie vor uns und schaut
uns zu und manchmal ist sie nicht da
wollen
sie schaut so wie ihr vater sie
missbraucht
also mit schuldig
schlimmer sie gab den befehl dazu
[Musik]
marie hat drei schwestern und einen
bruder sie ist die zweitälteste und
diejenige die am wenigsten schläge und
sexuelle übergriffe ertragen muss
diese treppe erinnere ich mich als wäre
es gestern gewesen wenn man mich so
sieht dann sehe ich nicht unglücklich
aus
deshalb erinnern sie sich so gut an
diese treppe
ich erinnere mich an das geräusch ich
erinnere mich genau wo es klappte
wenn er nach oben kam da wusste ich
immer auf welcher stufe er wahr gemacht
chile dürfte
die anzahl der stufen erinnern sie sich
daran ja
1600 vor wie oft ist es mir passiert
allein in meinem zimmer zu sein und wenn
er die treppe hoch stieg dann habe ich
gebetet er möge eine andere der
schwestern schlagen kommen
es tut mir leid
es ist fürchterlich sich zu wünschen
dass die andere die schläge abbekommt
und sie nicht selbst zu bekommen
[Musik]
hat ihr vater ihnen manchmal gedroht
falls sie von den geschehnissen erzählen
würden falls sie nicht gehorchen würden
nein es gab da keine drohungen wie du
darfst nicht davon sprechen weil es
eigentlich normal war deshalb sollten
sie es uns verbieten denn wir würden
sowieso nichts davon erzählen denn wir
waren uns nicht im klaren dass es etwas
schlimmes war das mussten sie gar nicht
wir würden sowieso nicht sagen wovon
sprechen in der schule stellten sie uns
ja keine solche fragen
[Musik]
auch sarah poewe hat jahrzehntelang
geschwiegen bis sie sich von der last
ihres geheimnisses befreien konnte
bisher realisierte dass ihr schweigen
sie erstickt und innerlich zerstört
die ehemalige miss schweiz und heutige
radio-moderatorin hätte sich gerne schon
als mädchen jemandem anvertraut aber die
familiäre situation ließ das nicht zu
wenn ich davon erzähle geht es mir nicht
gut sie werden sich trennen papa muss
ins gefängnis
man wird sagen es sei nicht wahr
es gibt ja die ganze zeit sehr viel was
im kopf passiert am ende weil ich so
verwirrt dass ich mir sagte dass ich das
nicht schaffen würde du sagst also
nichts schweigen ist einfacher wenn
man schweigt wenn man schweigt geht die
zerstörung weiter schritt für schritt
immer weiter und weiter und weiter
zwischen 5 und 13 muss sarah regelmäßig
die übergriffe ihres vaters ertragen wie
alle missbrauchten kinder hat sie mühe
zu verstehen dass es nicht normal ist
als fünfjährige versteht man nicht was
sexuelle lust ist wenn ein vater
versucht die sexuelle lust zu zeigen der
eigene vater sagt das ist schön nicht
wahr
papa du streichelt mich aber es ist
seltsam mir gefällt es nicht
es gab da keine gewalt aber die
manipulation ist derart groß dass man
sich verpflichtet fühlt aber der
ekelliste
musical haftet dass ein vater niemals
mit seiner kleinen tochter teilen sollte
manchmal nahm er mich zu seinen
geliebten mit ich habe erinnerungen an
pornografische bücher mit kindern
ich wurde da in ein universum voller
sexualität reingezogen
in der kindheit wird die eigene
wahrnehmung des lebens und des
familienlebens in der familie gebildet
grundsätzlich ist man da wie ein weißes
blatt alles was auf dieses blatt
geschrieben wird schreibt sich im kreis
der familie
wenn ein elternteil eine sexuelle
beziehung mit seinem kind eingeht wird
das kind davon ausgehen dass es das im
familienleben zu lernen geld so wird es
sehr schnell den schluss ziehen dass es
selbst unfähig ist etwas was normal
scheint zu leben
als sarah in die pubertät kommt beginnt
sie zu verstehen was sie ertragen muss
sie will die wahrheit sagen wendet sich
an ihre mutter doch diese will es nicht
hören ich bin damit bei meiner mutter
denkbar ungelegen gekommen
für mich war es aber dringend und musste
raus und ich sagte papa war nicht
korrekt zu mir
sie schaut mich an und sagt wie meinst
du das wie ist er nicht korrekt gewesen
und ich war nicht imstande etwas anderes
zu sagen ich konnte keine einzelheiten
erzählen ich sehe aber wie sie ihre
fassung verliert deko pose ich verstehe
dass sie versteht da sagt sie mir hört
zu wir gehen jetzt an eine familienfeier
wir werden am abend darüber sprechen sie
zieht ihre maske an ich ziehe meine
maske an und wir gehen los niemand merkt
etwas in dem moment als sie so etwas
monströses erfährt
die missachtung in der eigenen familie
treibt sarah dazu bestätigung in der
öffentlichkeit zu suchen
was für ein bild hatten sie von sich
selbst
ich habe ein bild eines kleinen toten
mädchens ja dass nichts hat als seinen
körper der mittlerweile gewachsen ist
diesen körper habe ich benutzt ich habe
ihn dazu benutzt meinen extremen wunsch
nach anerkennung zu befriedigen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es war ein mittel dazu seien ihr seht
mich ich bin da ich existiere schaut
mich anruft nur habe ich bald bemerkt
dass es leer war ich war von neuem eine
projektion von männern umringt mann ist
ein objekt weil es zu schön ist einiges
schweiz im bett zu haben
sie existiert nicht
was geschah mit ihrem körper wenn sie
mit männern im bett waren haben sie lust
empfunden
nein der körper ist ein objekt
seit dem ersten mal als er zum objekt
gemacht wurde erst ein objekt geblieben
trotz ihrer berühmtheit dem großen
öffentlichen zuspruch fühlt sich sarah
nicht wohl in dem körper den sie zur
schau stellt
die ehemalige miss schweiz ist gefangen
in einem gefühl von leere eine so große
lehre dass sie ihrem leben ein ende
setzen will
ich nehme alle medikamente die ich im
haus finden kann trinken wodka und
schreibe einen abschiedsbrief und lege
mich hin und
er wache im spital ich weiß nicht wie
lange ich im cora war war ich hab's
vermasselt eben meine erste reaktion
nach dem aufwachen war wieso bin ich
noch hier
ich war nicht imstande dem arzt
mitzuteilen es gibt eher schlecht weil
ich als kind von meinem vater
missbraucht wurde ich habe es erlebt
ruhig war unfähig ich wusste es ich
verstand dass aber ich wusste nicht dass
ich deshalb innerlich kaputt war darum
nennt man es dass traumatische
gedächtnis es ist dermaßen schmerzhaft
dass der schmerz irgendwohin verband
wird bis er eines tages explodiert
man muss verstehen dass sich beim
erleben eines traumas also beim erleben
einer zerstörerischen handlung
schutzmechanismen im hirn abspielen die
diese handlungen isolieren so verhindert
das gehirn stressreaktionen jedes mal
wenn die erinnerungen hochkommen wollen
diese schutzmechanismen sind manchmal
sehr mächtig und können ein vollkommenes
vergessen bewirken
michelle ist fünf jahre alt als ihr
onkel sie während eines
ferienaufenthaltes am meer sexuell
missbraucht ein traumatisches erlebnis
das für jahre aus ihrer erinnerung
verschwindet nur flüchtige bilder suchen
sie ab und zu heim
es sind unbeständige flashs die aber
immer wieder aufflackern das
wasser der fels und der schrei meiner
mutter zum glück hat meine mutter mich
aus seinen armen gerissen und gerufen
für auf ich verstand es nicht
ich habe sehr lange gebraucht um zu
verstehen was mir zugestoßen war mit 50
habe ich einen großen schock erlebt von
da an kamen schubweise erinnerungen ich
habe angefangen über mich und mein leben
nachzudenken
ein leben lang empfindet michelle dieses
diffuse unwohlsein mit 20 an suizid
versuch mit 30 ein aufenthalt in einer
psychiatrischen klinik ohne genau zu
verstehen was ihr fehlt
sie beginnt sich erst zu erinnern als
sie erfährt dass ihre beiden töchter
auch missbraucht worden sind die eine
von ihrem stiefvater die andere vom
selben onkel wie michelle
[Musik]
ich bekam eine flex zu sprechen und so
ist alles rausgekommen
meine amnesie hat aufgehört und ich habe
all meine kindheitserinnerungen
wiedergefunden
denn ich hatte eine lehre im hinterkopf
ich ging ohne gepäck voran ich hatte
keine wurzeln
[Musik]
mit den erinnerungen kommen auch bilder
der geschehnisse mit ihrem onkel hoch
doch sie sind wenig präzis
michael sucht den onkel am sterbebett
auf in der hoffnung ein geständnis zu
erhalten
eines tages sage ich ihm fred erkläre
mir war es für dich bedeutet
da hat er gestanden
das war schon sehr eindrücklich
was hat er gesagt
er sagt mir mein schatz wie gut es uns
ging es waren die schönsten ferien es
ging uns gut das wasser ging uns bisher
hielt es war eine liebesgeschichte
[Musik]
ich sagte ihm fremd wie alt warst du wie
alt war ich das geht doch nicht ich war
ein kind den ofen
er sagte aber nein mein schatz in der
familie ist sowas möglich dass gibt es
also für ihn war es eine
liebesgeschichte etwas wunderschönes
[Musik]
103 jahren
wo
immer er hat die wahrheit ans licht
gebracht das ist wichtig
sein geständnis war wichtig ja sehr
zutiefst ja es hat mich wütend gemacht
ich war angewidert aber es hat mich auch
entlastet
auch wenn er die geschichte bescheinigt
hat
das ist seine geschichte nicht meine
michael wird nie mit gewissheit erfahren
was damals an mir vor sich gegangen ist
aber durch das geständnis ihres onkels
kann sie an die wurzel des übels
gelangen dass sie seit jahren belastet
sie konnten sich nicht erinnern aber
trotzdem war da etwas dermaßen mächtiges
dass ihnen ihr halbes leben zerstört hat
dadurch ist mein leben verkümmert weil
sowas tötet uns aber wir müssen leben
ein halbes leben lang konnte michelle
nicht in worte fassen was in ihrer
kindheit geschehen war nun hat sie alles
aufgeschrieben hunderte von seiten aus
angst ihre erinnerung von neuem zu
verlieren diese geschichte steht für
mich ich habe mich wieder gefunden indem
ich sie entdeckt habe in dem ich mit ihr
gearbeitet habe ich werde sie niemals
vergessen aber sie verblasst kein hass
kein leiden mehr du entfernt sich fred
ich lass dich gehen
[Musik]
auch marie sprunger kann lange nicht
darüber reden was ihr als kind
widerfahren ist mit 20 wendet sie sich
an den bürgermeister ihres dorfes ein
mutiger schritt denn ihr bruder und ihre
drei schwestern schweigen weiterhin
damals stecken die kirche und die
obrigkeiten den kopf in den sand ich
müsste auch noch die schule erwähnen die
lehrer
professor die haben dinge gesehen sie
haben aber nichts gesagt weil das nicht
sehr interessant war die batterie saison
es gab wenig raum sich zu äußern es gab
keinen
was hat sie denn letztlich dazu bewogen
auszusagen
das ist die gute frage ich hatte den
gedanken zum bürgermeister des dorfes zu
gehen und daran eine gewisse hoffnung
geknüpft
ich frage mich heute noch was mir damals
durch den kopf gegangen ist
auf jeden fall gab es da eine große
kraft in mir die mich zum sprechen
drängte ich hatte also zu jenem
zeitpunkt verstanden dass etwas nicht
stimmte
vielleicht ist es mir just in dem moment
als ich aus dem haus geschasst wurde
bewusst geworden dass etwas überhaupt
nicht in ordnung war
ja bestimmt
haben sie auch die sexuellen übergriffe
erwähnt
nein
vielleicht habe ich etwas durchschimmern
lassen
ich erzähle von den misshandlungen dass
ich mich um meine jüngeren geschwister
sorge aber nein nicht das ich mich
erinnere die dinge klar bei ihrem namen
genannt zu haben
die clubbosse müller
aufgrund ihrer aussagen leitet die
gemeinde ein verfahren gegen ihre eltern
ein ihnen wird sofort das sorgerecht
entzogen
die kinder werden für einige monate in
einem heim untergebracht
dies führt dazu dass marie endgültig von
ihrer familie ausgeschlossen wird
[Musik]
von dem moment an in dem ich geredet
habe habe ich alles verloren ich rede
hier von meinem eigenen familienkreis
war endgültig auseinander gebrochen es
ist doch nicht zu glauben dass angesagt
wird das interessiert mich nicht also
bis mich interessieren würde es gemacht
nein ich habe es mir nicht ausgesucht
ich habe sehr leiden müssen und leider
hat es viele aspekte meines lebens
zerstört
ist zu viel für mich ich konnte nicht
mehr es war zu schwer ich wollte
endgültig schluss machen
aber das leben hat nicht gewollt dass
sie sterben
da habe ich beschlossen niemals meinen
nur zu halten und mich niemals zu
verstecken
marie michelle sarah sie alle
entwickelten die für inzest opfer
typischen störungen chronische
depression
selbstmordversuche selbstverletzendes
verhalten als folgeschäden der erlebten
übergriffe aber
auch weil sie mit ihrem leiden nicht
ernst genommen wurden
weil sie von ihrer familie keine hilfe
bekommt will sich sarah bei der justiz
gehör verschaffen
ich hatte die kraft zu einem anwalt zu
gehen als ich 25 jahre alt war ich sagte
mir dass wird es nun sein meine wut war
so groß sie musste raus es musste
bekanntwerden und bestraft
ich ging zu einem anwalt und erzählte
meine geschichte nach einigen recherchen
erklärte er mir in einem brief dass die
sache leider verjährt war um weniger
monate
heute setzt sich die ex miss schweiz
gegen die verjährung ein obwohl die
justiz nichts für ihren eigenen fall
unternehmen konnte beschließt sie ihren
vater anzuklagen auch weil er gegenüber
einer anderen angehörigen straffällig
geworden war ich glaube du willst einen
schlussstrich ziehen das wichtige ist
dass die menschheit die justiz klar
ausformuliert wird dass dinge passiert
sind die als tatsachen anerkannt wurden
total cool plötzlich erfahre ich dass es
weitergegangen erst beim recherchieren
es ist die ganze zeit über
weitergegangen in dem moment habe ich
mir gesagt dass es nun genug ist dieses
leid als vielen leuten zugefügt wird und
immer mit der behauptung dass alle
anderen ringsherum lügner sind wodurch
er die ganzen probleme verursacht das
müssen aufhören
die kriterien für das strafmaß
berücksichtigen die persönlichkeit des
täters als ganzes für jemanden der schon
als kind gravierendes verbrochen hat
steht im richter eine enorme bandbreite
an möglichkeiten zur verfügung
er kann für eine vergewaltigung drei
aber auch 10 jahre verhängen
die rechtsprechung kann niemanden
belangen oder verurteilen aufgrund von
taten die verjährt sind
allerdings kann sie zum beispiel
elemente berücksichtigen die ein opfer
erwähnt um aktuelle taten gegen ein
anderes opfer zu kontextualisierung die
kritische presse
[Musik]
trotz der gravierenden taten bringt
marie sprunger die kraft nicht auf vor
gericht zu gehen
können sie sich vorstellen wie ich mich
mit jeder meiner schwestern und meinem
bruder konfrontiere um in ihnen um jeden
preis die schmutzigen erinnerungen
wachzurufen
als einziger unter fünf geschwister
nicht spricht wäre ich ja eindeutig die
verrückte und die lügnerin
könnten sie mit dem gedanken leben das
ihr vater heute für seine taten ins
gefängnis geht
genau da liegt das problem
das ist das berühmte problem der
loyalität gegenüber den eltern
das war ein wichtiges thema in meiner
therapie und das ist sehr kompliziert es
existiert eine art von tiefer abscheu
vor den eltern die absolut verheerend
ist
gleichzeitig es ist schrecklich das zu
sagen hat man das gefühl an sie
gefesselt zu sein weil man ja von ihnen
abstammt und da kann man nichts dagegen
tun
stellen sie sich vor ich als tochter von
ich würde diese leute die justiz würde
diese leute ins gefängnis stecken
man wird nicht geheilt mann überlebt mit
einem urteilsspruch kann man aber etwas
besser leben
tatsächlich ist es das wort das
befreiende kräfte hat die erste phase
tut weh aber danach folgt die
erleichterung ab die erleichterung etwas
zu ende gebracht zu haben
diese erleichterung ist im moment des
gerichtsurteils dann sehr deutlich im
moment des schuldspruchs also dann
nämlich wird die schuld dorthin gelegt
wo sie auch hingehört auf die seite des
täters das bringt den opfern eine große
erleichterung denn dieses verharren im
zustand des ungehörten opfers ist
vielleicht schmerzhafter als schmerzen
im prozess
weil sich die zeiten geändert haben und
vor allem dank der unterstützung ihrer
mütter hatten chloé und claire den mut
ihre väter anzuzeigen ein schwieriges
unterfangen ohne beweise wie zum
beispiel dna proben oder zeugen kann
sich die staatsanwaltschaft nur auf die
aussagen der opfer stützen
das ist tatsächlich das schlimmste ich
habe zb die psychologische gutachterin
mehrmals besucht meine mutter auch
jedes mal wurden unsere aussagen in
frage gestellt es ist als hätte man eine
wunde die nie verheilen darf
muss drei jahre auf das urteil warten
drei beschwerliche jahre danach gilt
ihre aussage als überzeugend genug um
ihren vater für schuldig zu befinden die
justizbehörden sind sich bewusst dass
die verfahren für die opfer oft sehr
zermürbend sind deshalb sind die
gerichte bestrebt den fokus stärker auf
die opfer zu legen das bundesgericht
präzisiert dass es bei vergehen sexuelle
natur die in einem geschlossenen raum
zwischen zwei personen begangen wurden
möglich ist ein urteil auf der
alleinigen basis der opfer aussage zu
fällen wenn diese schlüssig und
glaubwürdig ist und zu den anderen
elementen der akten fest
es existiert auch eine rechtsprechung
des bundesgerichtes gemäß der es möglich
ist die anforderungen an die exaktheit
der beschreibung und des ortes ein wenig
zu relativieren
im falle von wiederholten sexuellen
vergehen insbesondere wenn sich diese
gegen kinder richten
description de dieu
floris vater wird für schuldig befunden
er wird zu einer geldstrafe von 300
tagen 30 franken mit einer
bewährungsfrist von vier jahren
verurteilt
obwohl es nur einmal passiert ist und es
keine vergewaltigung war macht so etwas
trotzdem das leben eines kindes kaputt
darum hätte ich es gerne gehabt wenn man
ihn eingesperrt hätte
ich war in meinem kopf eingesperrt ganz
allein
claire befindet sich noch mitten im
verfahren zwei jahre nach ihrer anhörung
bei der polizei ist die
staatsanwaltschaft immer noch damit
beschäftigt verschiedene zeugen zu
befragen zurzeit weiß die jugendlichen
nicht wann das urteil gefällt wird
ich erwarte dass die justiz die dinge
zurecht rückt und meine aussage
anerkennt und er das inzest schuldig
gesprochen wird ich erwarte diese zu
erkennen
die sanktionen geht mich ehrlich gesagt
nichts an
das wichtigste ist die bestätigung dass
es wirklich so passiert es
ich denke er wird nie zugeben was er mir
angetan hat darum erwarte ich von ihm
absolut nichts allerdings verlange ich
von der justiz dass er für seine taten
verurteilt wird
das schlimmste ist für mich die tatsache
dass er es nicht zugeben dass ich all
diese jahre abwarten musste in denen ich
immer wieder dasselbe wiederholen musste
hätte er es gleich zugegeben hätte ich
das alles nicht durchmachen müssen
michelle marie
claire sarah sie alle haben ihren weg
gefunden neu zu beginnen
sarah poewe mutter zweier kinder setzt
sich heute für die prävention ein die ex
miss schweiz ist partien von pathos
einer vereinigung die in den schulen der
französischen schweiz präventionskurse
anbietet im kampf gegen gewalt sie setzt
aufklärungs dafür ein
für mich ist dies sehr wichtig bin ich
als kind gewusst hätte dass gewisse
dinge nicht normal sind hätte ich
vielleicht vorher ausbrechen können
es ist unglaublich wichtig den jungen
menschen zu erklären was normal und was
nicht normal ist wenn man ihnen keine
werkzeuge zur verfügung stellt ist es
für sie absolut unmöglich zu begreifen
was vor sich geht genau diese
unwissenheit macht es den tätern so
leicht die jungen menschen zu
missbrauchen
und vergiss nicht du hast das recht nein
zu sagen
claire hat nach zwei jahren
psychotherapie ihr gleichgewicht
wiedergefunden
sie führt wie alle 16 jährigen
gymnasiastinnen ein normales
teenagerleben mit ihren aussagen will
sie auch gleichaltrigen helfen
wenn ich wenigstens jemanden dabei
helfen kann zu verstehen was vor sich
geht bin ich froh dass alles was mir
zugestoßen ist ist nicht schön es ist
hässlich will ich es in dem ich andere
unterstütze weniger hässlich machen kann
dann freut mich das
für marie die fotografin ist es ein
anliegen allen schweigenden opfern eine
stimme zu geben
[Musik]
chloe studiert psychologie an der uni in
genf sie spielt mit dem gedanken
vielleicht eines tages mit kindern zu
arbeiten
heute sieht sich keine der frauen als
opfer sie verstehen sich als überlebende
mehr noch als kämpferinnen und ihre
beste waffe ist das wort
[Musik]
du erzählst eine geschichte offen nicht
anonymisiert deshalb
weil es für mich keine schande ist der
einzige der sich schämen müsste ist mein
vater
ich will dass die leute wissen dass ich
nicht lüge und meine familie auch nicht
es ist die wahrheit
du hast nichts zu verbergen
das wort der frau das wort des
kleinkindes hat nicht länger einen
unzureichenden charakter es ist
maßgebend und muss gehört werden das ist
es was sich geändert hat wenn das
schweigen gebrochen wird entsteht eine
klare starke botschaft nicht wir als
opfer müssen uns schämen die schande
liegt dort wo sie hingehört nämlich bei
den tätern
resistiv widerstand leisten diese worte
wiederhole ich immer wieder widerstand
leisten und ich werde widerstand leisten
ich werde weiterhin widerstand leisten
man kann mir sagen was man will das ist
mir völlig egal ob profi schon fett
sie hat nicht nur ein opfer bei weitem
nicht
[Musik]